le scandale at il été inventée de toutes
pièces non non on va avoir la réponse
magali barrez vous connaissez toute la
sphère magali car l'amour est laid dans
votre agence oui d'accord
julien mannon donc ils sont 11e alors et
qui blesse que la première question que
se posent tous les téléspectateurs
c est ce que ça a été d'ailleurs va
faire un tour de plus si vous n'avez
nous dire après d'ailleurs oui gilles
verdez dit non pour l'instant bien
entendu que ça n'a pas été inventée de
toute pièce où ça a été un buzz
orchestré ces efforts mais c'est grave
je vous dis moi c'est pas un buzz
orchestré d'ailleurs elle a retiré ses
excuses elle a été mise sous pression
toute la nuit toute la matinée
magali giat de vous entendre parce que
vous n'êtes pas innocents sur cette
affaire mais je laisserai vous écrit
dessus d'abord bien entendu que la
production a agit bien entendu que les
marseillais ont fait bloc
il ya eu une volonté si vous voulez de
dire que ce n'était rien mais je
maintiens que il ya eu cette affaire de
sorcellerie qui n'est pas la seule dans
la télé réalité de ce que vous allez
poser les questions
gilles verdez bien entendu vous êtes là
pour ça oui alors j'ai contacté des
candidats des marseillais qui m'ont dit
qu'en fait kevin donc est le compagnon
de carla sera examiné en urgence à dubaï
pour tenter de convaincre maeva de
s'excuser de dire que toute cette
histoire était fausse
apparemment la ligne de défense de carla
c'est de dire qu'elle aurait été victime
d'extorsion de fonds et qu'en fait elle
aurait fait ça sous la pression de cette
fameuse voyante qu'elle voyait depuis
ses 18 ans mais la candidate que j'ai
contacté m'a dit que même si elle avait
été sous la pression de cette voyante
elle aurait pu lui demander des choses
moins grave le problème c'est qu'elle
lui a demandé des choses très graves et
à l'encontre de son entourage
donc certains candidats des marseillais
trouve ça très louche alors oui qu'est
où ils vous connaissez moi je pense que
kevin donc qui est le compagnon de carla
il est parti à dubaï il s'est déplacé
parce qu'il s'est dit pas de notes
vocales pas de textos rien écrit il n'y
a aucune trace
je vais aller mettre un petit coup de
pression parce que j'ai peut-être des
bye j'ai peut-être des doses contre vous
aussi donc maintenant vous allez vous
taire sur ma femme vous allez arrêter de
faire des histoires pas possible sur les
réseaux sociaux
et ça a fonctionné puisque maeva amis
justement ce message en s'excusant
qu'elle a effectivement tu as raison mon
âge il retiré par la suite mais tout de
même aujourd'hui on est en train de se
dire est ce que c'est vrai est ce que
c'est pas vrai alors qu'avant on va voir
gilles vous saurez si ça d'ivry sissani
faut absolument japonais magali
il va défoncer marche pas aujourd'hui
kim
je pense qu à padoue avait suivi cette
affaire ou pas oui et j'ai suivi et ben
comme tout le monde mais je pense qu a
pas de fumée sans feu après je suis
contre l'acharnement qui assure carla
parce qu'il ya toujours la présomption
d'innocence
maintenant c'est pas nouveau on sait que
beaucoup de stars que ce soit katy perry
bien de ces ont vendu leur âme au diable
il ya beaucoup de c quoi cette histoire
de sorcellerie vous avez déjà fait appel
à la société jamais de la vie ouhlala
1,20 dollar mon dieu qu'est-ce que vous
connaissiez cette histoire parce que
peut-être qu'elle a essayé de faire de
faire appel à cette voyante c'est
qu'elle a été peut-être prises au piège
après je sais pas elle aurait eu du
chantage je sais pas je connais pas la
fin de cette histoire apparemment vous
les connaissez ces personnes ne les
connais bien sûr parce que dans votre
chouchou bonjour je sais pas qui vous
êtes et donc oui non mais vous les
connaissez et donc moi s car là c'est
pas forcément ma grande copine mais mais
cela ne mérite pas cet acharnement
j'aimerais savoir ce que ne dit pas non
mais je pense que dans dans leur univers
à eux je pense que le buzz fait partie
intégrante de thé ça de bala je pense
que c'est ils peuvent pas vivre sans
donc je ne sais pas ce qui est vrai ce
qu'il faut parce que a priori on n'en
sait rien maintenant les vidéos qu'on
aime ou hier elle semble bien réelle
mais un bien réel maintenant de là à y
croire moi je pense que c'est plus un
bleu à buzz orchestré plutôt qu'autre
chose mais sûrement que la papesse des
vérités à la réponse